Först Föderskor nu till exempel, som använder dina produkter.
Jag kommer inte ihåg exakt vad du sa men det var en sån här...
Ni tolv procent?
Alltså vi sålde det.
En gång att ha tolv procent av en marknad, det är liksom...
Eller kunde du, för det är ju helt visariskt.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Kenobi generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Katja Majer från Plym till dagens avsnitt av Make Sweden Stronger.
Och Katja har ett bolag som säljer, kan man säga, efterförlossningsprodukter till kvinnor.
Är det en nisch, Katja?
Ja, det är det.
En brett produkt för att hjälpa till i återhämtningen efter en förlossning.
Ja.
Kan du ge några exempel på produkter?
Bara så att vi...
Jag tänker att detta är liksom ett företag som har man precis fött barn, då vet man vad det är för bolag, men alla vi som inte precis har fött barn har inte koll på det.
Nej men det är ju...
När man kommer hem efter en förlossning, oavsett om man har fött barn vaginal eller med kylsasnitt, så är man ganska skörd och öm i kroppen.
Och det går att återhämta sig med mindre smärta än vad vi har med lite hjälpmedel.
Och det är väl det jag kände att vi...
Ska jag liksom dra hur allting började kanske?
Ja men gör det.
Det är väl en ganska trevlig start.
Ja, ha kul.
Jag var gravid 2020 och födde min dotter i maj.
Och det var corona.
Och jag tyckte att jag var ganska påläst om vad som väntar under en förlossning och så vidare.
Men ändå så kom jag hem och skickas hem med typ hej då, vi kollar ditt knip om åtta veckor.
Som att det var relevant.
Det var så här, kvinnor har gjort det här i tusenpals år och jag kände såhär, nej, såhär ska det typ inte vara.
Ska vi ha såhär ont att vi inte kan sitta på en stor?
Ska vi blöda såhär mycket?
Ska vi inte ha någon bedövning för underlivet som har fett ett barn nu?
Jag kände såhär, det är väl inte värda mer.
Vi ska ha en feministisk regering, i Sverige är vi i framkant, säger vi, det är ingen jämställdhet.
Och här vart det bara såhär, nej, vi har gjort det här i tusentals år.
Men fick du inte en påse från apoteket med en napp och en nappflaska?
Det är väl ändå...
Vad ska jag göra med den nappen?
Nej jag fattar, jag fattar.
Man får både en kit från apotek och de här tjänarna, men det är ju fokus på bebis och baby showers är också fokus på bebisen.
Och den här påsen som finns på förlossningen som är spons, det är också fokus på bebis.
Du får bli er.
Men sen så för mamman, nej, de flesta snor de här nät trosorna man får på bebis.
De snor binderna, man vågar inte fråga.
Och du behöver de här förlossningbinderna i typ, jag blödde i sex veckor.
Jag kanske inte hade behövt den storleken så länge, men ändå så här, det borstar ju blod.
Och så här, du blödde genom lakan.
Alltså att ingen vågar prata om det här.
Och att man inte förbereder sig och är kittad så att du inte blöder genom lakan och kläder.
Och känner att det är pinsamt, fast du bara är hemma.
Då känner man sig som en sjukhuspatient när man kommer hem.
Och det fanns inga produkter som hjälper till och bara gör den här vardagen som redan är fruktansvärd, omtungande, inte bara med smärta men hormon och sömnbrist och en bebis, och man ska få till andningen och brösten är ju fruktansvärt ont.
Och på det så som, jag vet liksom i andra kulturer så lämnar man inte kvinnan ensam, de första 20 dygnen.
Det är någon som fixar mat, det är någon som plockar, det är någon som bara tar bebisen och dockar in den i ringtutte typ.
Och i USA jag har en, och det är så här allting började, att jag har en amerikansk vän som bor i Sverige, och hon gav mig, okej vi börjar såhär, en svensk vän som bor i USA som berättar om förlossningen i USA, som då sa att det här får man få.
Du betalar jättemycket till försäkringsbolagen, men mamman får i alla fall ett recovery kit, som hon ska ta hem för att underlätta sin återhämtning.
Typ en bedömningsspray, typ isbinder, typ en sån här intimdusch som då kallas för Perry bottle, som är jättestort och jättevanligt.
Så det är en självklarthet.
Alla som föder, oavsett hur du föder, tar en sån här hemma.
Och jag kände inte till det.
Tillstå, jag kommer hem några dagar på spartum, och när man säger på spartum så är det den tiden efter att mamma förlöst barnen, än när det varit med annars låsning.
Och så har jag då en amerikansk vän här hemma som gav mig en sån här Perry bottle och som sa, använd den här varje gång för att rengöra underlivet mellan att du byter binderna.
Jag vet att vården sa, ställ dig i duschen varje gång för att rengöra underlivet.
När du byter binder.
Och jag har varit såhär, men du byter binder sju gånger inom samma dygn.
Ska jag ställa mig i en dusch då och bli blöt och samtidigt försöka hålla i en bebis.
Det blir såhär, och det är det jag känner, hur kan du inte ha kommit längre?
Och jag har varit så chockad och jag har varit så arg.
Och jag sitter med den här flaskan som är så fantastisk.
För det är bara en enkel liten flaska som du fyller med i vatten.
Som du sätter dig på toaletten och så bara sprayar du lite vatten.
Bara för att känna sig jummet, vatten.
Det är väldigt skönt.
Och så värme.
När du är svullet, du vill inte torka med toalettpapper.
Det känns som sandpapper.
Du vill inte röra dig någonstans där nu.
Du är sprucken och du har stign.
Det här vattnet som bara såhär...
Wow, det var helt fantastiskt.
Det är då jag bara sa till min man, så sitter jag och bara...
Hur fan kan jag inte ha det här i Sverige?
Jag fattar inte.
Och han bara, få in det i Sverige.
Och då har jag...
Mitt yrke är ju i något helt annat.
Jag älskar hur du är ultrapassionerad kring detta.
Och bara, fan varför har vi inte detta?
Ta in det då.
Det är det mest typiska svaret.
Det är sånt åsikterna har sagt.
Och så sitter jag där och bara, jag har jobbat med något helt annat.
Jag har jobbat inom kvinnors och hårs-
och ungdomsrörelsen, inom valsutsatta ungdomar, inom kvinnor i människahandel, och sedan något helt annat, inom volontärarbete.
Och jag kan ingenting om det.
Han bara säger så här, ta in den i Sverige, och jag bara, vad gör ni?
Och hur då?
Han bara, gå in på Alibaba.
Jag har varit så här, vad är det?
Ingen aning.
Och det är väl det där i början.
Jag var typ åtta veckor på svartrum och kände så här, okej, jag har den här flaskan, jag vill att kvinnor i Sverige ska också ha den här flaskan.
Hur gör vi då?
Och då började jag liksom, det var i Google, då fanns det inte Chucky Péter.
Allt mitt bolag hade flygit om det fanns något.
Det kommer att finnas detta before and after.
Då gick jag in, först och kollade lite, jag googlade fabriker i Sverige, jag försökte ändå tänka hållbart nära att man kan besöka sin fabrik här och vara med i processen.
Men det var ju sådana jättestora uppstartskostnader, de vet inte vad det här är för produkt, det finns liksom inga maskiner som tillverkar, det går att tillverka men det var uppstartskostnader på flerahundratusenten.
Men i Kina så fanns det ju hur många devendörer som helst som tar fram en sån här Perry bottle, för att det finns ju andra kontinenter, och i andra kulturer och används liksom flitigt.
Har det inte funnits, bara för någon sorts transparens där, du och jag har ju snackat någon gång för ett halvår, känner eller något sånt där, vi snackade lite allmänbusiness, jag har lite koll på ditt bolag men, men de här finns, har det liksom inte funnits sådana här flaskor innan eller är det bara att det har funnits konstiga sådana flaskor på svenska marknaden?
Var du först på svenska marknaden med den här?
Ja, just med en sådan flaskor.
Är inte det lite bizarrigt då, eller vad är det som har gjort att det inte har funnits i Sverige innan?
Om det är så pass stor produkt?
Det är ingen jättekomplicerad produkt om vi ska vara rent kassa.
Jag håller helt med.
Det har inte funnits så mycket i Europa heller när jag har rekat.
Alltså inte alls.
USA var det stora, Kina och de masiatiska länderna.
Men annars tror jag att till och med andra kulturer där man kanske är rengörande i livet.
I Italien, där har de ju bidéer, det är så du rengör under livet.
I Finland har du en dusch som är inkopplad vid toaletten, så du rengör ändå.
Det har säkert funnits i olika sätt, i mellanöstern rengör du, men inte just en sån där flaska som har ett sånt munstycke som du drar ut och sen vinklar så att själva sprutet är på underlivet.
Det är liksom en hygienisk placka på underlivet så att du inte stoppar ner hela handen.
Du har fortfarande handen ovanför.
Jag förstår.
Det är bara spännande att det inte har funnits.
Det är som du säger, man tänker att vi ska ligga i framkant.
Ja.
Det fanns någon enstalka krem, det fanns ingenting, det fanns inga isbinder.
Vården var såhär, gör isbinder.
Då ska man ta en binda, man ska hälla vatten på den, sen ska den ligga i frysen, och sen ska du ta den här frysa kalorna, hårda bindan, och det är något underligt.
Du har ju, men såhär har vi gjort.
Och jag är såhär, nej vi har dött längs den vägen.
Vi har inte alls klarat oss något.
Vi har gjort det bästa av situationen, som vi gör till vardags.
Allting, jag blir beredd av det snabbt.
Och det är därför jag kände att det här måste bilanseras i Sverige.
Så tänkte jag att det kan väl inte vara så svårt.
Och vi började såhär, det här är bara en hobby.
Min enda inställning var att det här har hjälpt mig så mycket, det här är självklart i andra länder, det ska vara lika självklart här.
Så som om du köper en bröstpump eller ammingsregel eller vad som helst, så ska det finnas för kvinnorna.
Jag hade inte det här business-tänket, att jag skulle tjäna pengar eller nånting.
Det var helt såhär, jag snackade med min man Filip.
Han sa att vi inte reste i år, det är corona, så här har du en liten pott.
Så följ din lilla passion.
Men det var svårt, det var svårt att lansera en produkt som inte finns, en produkt som inte behövs tidigare.
Eller hur ska man säga, som...
Nej, hur kom du igång med, när du väl hade fått hem produkten där?
Hur fick du ut det till marknaden?
För att nu är det, nu hoppar jag lite här i förväg, men visst är det så att du har ganska stor procent av, om man först föddeskor nu till exempel, som använder dina produkter.
Jag kommer inte ihåg exakt vad du sa, men det var en såhär, jag hajar det till.
Ni tolv procent?
Alltså vi sålde förra året.
En gav 12% av en marknad, det är liksom, eller kunde du ju efter, det är helt bizarrt.
Det är ju superhäftigt.
Ja, men hur nådde du till, hur kom du igång där?
Så första var ju att, det var ju svårt att sätta ett namn på det här, vad ska vi kalla den för, och beskriva behovet, och säga in det här, som jag kan ingenting om ärtnadsföring.
Jag grundade bolaget först med en tjejkompis som inte var mamma, men som vi tänkte att det var corona och hon var permitterad, vi hade jätteroligt samman, så det var en väldigt rolig resa.
Sen så valde jag att gå vägen själv, och det är vi fortfarande jättenära vänner, så det har gått jättebra.
Men vi båda visste inte riktigt hur vi skulle göra, och googla oss fram och bara testa det här.
Men apoteken känns, det här är ett nytt produkt, och de gravida har en lista med tusentals saker som de ska köpa till bebisen och till sig själva oftast.
Och då är, för att minska alla olika plattformar och platser och så vidare, så vill vi visa, det är både förtrådiggivande med apotek, du köper flera saker till andra, och då kan du skaffa flera saker på din lista.
Och om det är en helt nytt produkt, då känns listan som att om apoteken har tagit in den här, så är det någonting som är bra.
Och det var svårt med hemsidan, så tänkte vi också självklart, vi lanserade, vi gick in på Fiverr och det fanns inga pinjar, det här är vår familjekassa.
Så vi tog en sån här Fiverr-lösning som byggde upp en hemsida med WordPress och commerce och shadowpool, den såg väl ut som en jorden.
Är det den ni fortfarande har?
Nej, vi bytte till Shopify sen.
Jag tänkte säga att ni har en väldigt behaglig hemsida, den passar ju i formspråket perfekt.
Ja men skitsamma, nej ni gick vidare med apoteket, jag fastnade.
Vi gick vidare med apoteket men det var inte lätt, det måste jag ändå säga.
Jag mejlar och jag försöker göra en...
Det är en produkt, det är också så här, kanske man har ett helt sånt humän som man ska sälja in, men vi ska sälja in en flaska och en produkt.
Då är det viktigt att först skicka in mina adressen till inköparna, jag ser att de här processerna för att komma in på apoteken är extremt komplicerade och man går ut till rätt person, det finns olika revideringsfönster, det här fungerar och det är jättebra.
Det finns ju en tanke om det också, men jag ville bara, jag vet när man är så himla passionerad, jag vill bara få ut den så fort som möjligt till alla.
Jag hade gjort en beställning på 2000 flaskor som jag har nu hemma i mitt garage.
Det var inte så lätt.
Det var, jag mailar, jag påminner, och då mitt mail är ganska långt.
Det är så här, jag går in på det här att jag tycker att vi kvinnor är värre än bättre efter vård.
Just det jag sa i början, att Annakind, det ska vara jämställd och här glöms vi helt bort.
Den här är en räddare innan den som underrättar.
Och jag nådde ändå fram till rätt personer som trodde att det här måste vara manmår, det måste vara någon som känner igen det här.
Och tack och lov att det är oftast kvinnor som sitter på de inköpsavdelningarna inom det området.
Det var någon man som svarade.
Och inte så, förstår mig rätt, såklart det kallar man som sitter på inköpsavdelningen.
Det är lugnt, man får generalisera i den här podden.
Ja men liksom, jag behöver någon som fattar snattan.
Ja, som bara har vi inte detta rejännes dokumentet?
Och så går man in och kollar, fan vi har inte detta, ja det är klart vi borde ha såhär.
Ja exakt, och det är på den vägen.
Så då var det ett apotek som trodde på mig, jag har varit så himla tacksam, och sedan ett annat och ett annat, och sedan kunde man använda det sammen.
Men vi finns ju på den här online apoteken.
Kan vi inte credda det första, vilka var de första som?
Ja, det var App och Hem faktiskt.
Okej.
Och de...
Kommer du ihåg vad hon ätte inköpan som bara skickade svaret?
Madeleine, jag måste hålla upp det där.
Ja, stor shout out till Madeleine som trodde på det.
Okej, och vad hände sen?
För det var ju inte bara en produkt sen, var det de som efterfrågade fler eller var det du som...
Ja, de flesta frågade såklart om det fanns fler, men det var ju rent såhär, vilken är den nästa produkt?
Jag tänkte inte så mycket, det här var liksom hero-produkten, det är den här som ska ut.
Och sen var det såhär, okej men nu har vi lite mer pengar, nu kan vi ta in en tidig produkt, men det går ju långsamt.
Man får ju tänka på att jag också är föräldraledig, jag har mitt första barn.
Jag går tillbaka till mitt gamla jobb på deltid.
Jag är en fantastisk tidigare chef som stöttade både Plym och att du kan gå tillbaka till 50 procent.
Sen får jag ett andra barn, man får ändå tänka att det här är, och det kan man ju prata mer om hur man hanterar småbarns ljus och eget företagande, men det går ju i den pakten som vi kan hantera.
Och då jobbade vi inte såhär, jag tog avkall på föräldraledighet, så fort barnet somnade så var jag satt mig vid datorn.
Jag var inte den här latteborsan som gick runt på stan och var med och killade och tog promenader.
För så fort som barnet såg, då satt jag mig vid datorn.
Och så är det, och jag är väldigt tacksam över att min man också som driver eget också satt på kvällarna.
Så då kunde vi sitta från klockan åtta till tolv ett.
Vi samlas på nätterna.
Så en produkt efter den andra.
Och sen är det också svårt när man är själv.
Jag har ingen att bolla med.
Jag har några vänner och så vidare, men det är svårt att veta vad och hur mycket och antal.
Samtidigt ska jag lära mig lager, packa order själv hemma, hur det värderar min tid.
Och sen mot Kina, ska vi ta in leverantörer kanske här vid, närmare i Europa eller i Sverige, och vad kostar det, och liksom, ja, svårt alltså.
Absolut, jag förstår det.
Men vad, när blev det, för nu jobbar du på detta, hela tiden eller?
Hur gick, när skedde det, var det en chansning eller var det att du hade nått den nivån, kan du ta med den, transition, den?
Ja, nej men jag tror att när jag sedan skulle gå tillbaka efter att jag fött mitt andra barn då, min son, och skulle gå tillbaka till mitt tidigare jobb, det som ändå liksom, lönjobbet, ja, så sa min gamla chef att så här, Katja, nu får du fundera på om du, vad du vill göra, du vill jättegärna ha tillbaka dig, alltså du vill ingenting annat.
Men det finns en risk att du kanske känner dig otillräcklig.
Att säga, jag kommer vilja så mycket med prym, jag kommer så här, och så bara, är det en dravid mässa samtidigt som vi kanske har en bollande trärutbildning?
Vad gör jag då?
Och redan att jag känner mig otillräcklig för att så här, jag jobbar såhär på kvällen när jag har med prym, så ska jag på det liksom jobba dagtid.
Det var liksom ett läge där alltså, antingen så satsar jag eller så får man typ ha en liten sag business men jag ville det.
Alla i hela världen måste få den här produkten.
Det var ju så jag kände att det finns så många fler produkter som man kan ta fram inom alltså allt så här, typ den här bedömningspridningen.
Varför har vi inte det?
Det är ett läkemedel och jag tänker inte gå in på det för jag kan inte det men bara sådana saker att så här, det finns så många fler hjälpmedel och produkter som jag vill ta fram och det kommer inte att hinna om jag har ett annat dagligt jobb.
Det är ju relativt tydligt för alla som lyssnar att det här är en passionsgrej.
Det andra jobbet som du hade låter också som en passionsgrej eller i alla fall ett emotionellt dränerande jobb då.
Att köra två sådana samtidigt som barn, ska man göra ett sidorjobb då får man ha ett automatiskt jobb och man får ha ett passionsjobb.
Man kan inte ha två passionsjobb, det funkar inte.
Jag kände det också, jag kommer alltid vara den här jag kommer vara den här kvinnohors-tanten senare.
Jag får bara lägga dig på pauset.
Vad får jag köra på med det här först?
Yes, kan du ta oss genom resan hur bolaget har växlat upp från de här 2000 flaskorna och sedan lite vilken produkt kom in sen, varför valde ni att ta in den produkten?
Ni började gå mot första kund som var an på hem och sedan vart är ni nu?
Och vad är nästa, bara lite timelineen.
Nej men det var väl en produkt, det går ju i den takten som det gör och sedan skyndar man sig själv.
Så det var ju Isbindan och sedan så...
Var det också en grej som inte fanns?
Det finns inte, nej.
Finns det också utan lands eller är det liksom ja ja men man kan göra egen man, nu har jag också två barn och jag födde ju också under 2020 så det var ju dessutom, eller jag födde men min fru födde.
Och det var ju dessutom så om du nu säger att folk inte var med så jag fick inte vara på sjukhuset efteråt utan de skickade hem mig.
Så jag var ju väldigt ensam i det där rummet efteråt.
Det är en väldigt skum process men man drar inte upp en klump is.
Det heter det mest.
Till och med jag kan förstå att det låter weird.
Ja exakt och då var det så här men den här kan man både ha, du kan ha den i kylen, du kan ha den i form av en binda, den har lite specielle kulor som fortfarande gör att den är formbar fast den är frysad.
Sen så är den så att du kan ha den i trosorna bara en stund, man ska ha den typ tio minuter eller en kvart bara när du som mest svullen för att dämpa och lindra surmnaden och smärtan.
Sen ska du inte ha den ännu mer, så det är bara så här du lägger dig på sängen bara tio minuter, låta den få göra sitt och sen så får man kämpa vidare.
Men den kan man också ha varm, typ som en vetekudde, du kan lägga den på brösten för att mjölken ska rinna till när du har spända bröst.
Men där känner jag att det är mer, jag tog fram den för att ha den som en form som en isbinda, sen har den en annan funktion, good for, kul för dem.
Nej men det är jättebra.
Men där finns det vetekuddar och då känner jag hur fokuset här minskar smärtan vid en eftervaginal förlossning.
Jag väljer färger och former som inte känns så sjukhuspatentiga när man kommer hem och att det inte är utskrivet av en läkare.
Jag försöker tänka hela tiden att de här nätroserna som var väldigt sköna, verkligen, jag snodde med dem flera stycken och jag gick i dem och levde i dem i en månad.
Det var samma där, att du kanske vill ta en bild när du står ut i spegeln med bebisen i famnen.
Du har ju en enorm hjärtebinda, den syns ju rakt igenom.
Det här är inga bilder som du kanske sätter upp i ditt hem eller visar andra.
Eller ta emot och besöka.
Vi var ju så fort vår dotter föddes, vi kom hem, vi skrev till tre olika grannar, de kom allihopa genom samma dygn och ville välkomma det här barnet.
Det är för att jag och min man får väldigt mycket energi av att träffa andra personer och vill visa upp vår lilla gubbel kring.
Det är där jag också tänkte att när man tar emot besök, har någon hemma eller kan det vara skönt att bara ha ett par troströr som inte känns så sjukhuspatientliga och att man inte ser sig i spegeln som en sjuk person.
När man har varit, du liksom, det här är din borget, du har ju varit med om någonting extraordinärt och din kropp har gjort någonting helt fantastiskt.
De borde belöna, alltså inte bara på min kasselig trost.
Då tog jag fram ett par svapar, som är lite mer, inte lika syktrur, om du kan ha den här bindaren utan att man ser att du har en binda och har lite mer hårt kött, typ som era boxers typ, som man kan gå runt i hem och bara leva i och som andas och som håller bilden på plats på maten så att man inte känner sig osäker att man blöder genom sängen.
Och sen en sittkudde som ser ut som en donut, men den har ett hål i mitten så du kan inte sitta utan att det trycker hårt mot underlivet.
Men så har den ändå ett fodral runt så att du inte ser att det är en donut.
Så att den ska smälta in lite grann och just så att det inte ska se ut som en hemorröjderkudde som de så fint egentligen heter.
Men jag har bara känt vatten och heta sitt kudde.
Ja exakt, man måste ju inte döpa den till det, folk fattar ju.
Så på den vägen är det och det är ju fler, jag finkar ju produktutvecklingen egentligen det som jag vill sitta mest med och det som tar längst tid in sig också.
Men jag gör i den takt som jag kan hantera.
Men är du fortfarande ensam i bolaget och driver det?
Ja, inte just nu.
Jag är ensam som driver det eller grundar det.
Men jag har en tjej som heter Lisa som hjälper mig just nu på heltid.
Med marknadsföring och adning och allt runt omkring.
Så här är det ju med start-ups och det vet ju du också, alla gör allt.
Men jag har för mig rätt att avlöna och ha en heltidsanställd vilket känns jättebra.
Hon bor i Göteborg så det är på distans, för jag sitter i Stockholm, men hon jobbar på hela tiden.
Vilket känns jättebra.
Och nu har jag haft en praktikant i tio veckor.
Och då har jag varit såhär, kik nu är vi typ tre.
Det var jättekul, nu känns det lite mer som att såhär, och de gör saker som jag inte vet om, såhär wow, det känns, nu känns det på riktigt.
Ja, jag fattar.
Med all respekt för, alltså nu är ju inte företaget så jättegammalt, du har ju hållit på några år, men produkten är ju väldigt logisk, och du har ju en ganska, som vi nämnde, du hade 12 procent där av, är det första gången födelsskorna?
Vi vet det faktiskt.
Och jag tror faktiskt att det är fler om födelsskor, för de vet vad du är med om.
De vet hur mycket du kommer bröda.
Och liksom så.
När jag är på mässor och pratar med kunderna eller de gravida, då är de ändå ganska, de förstfödelsskorna är ganska avvaktande.
Jag vill inte ta ut någonting i förskott.
Man bara, du ska ju föda ett barn.
Ja, det kommer kännas.
Det kommer kännas, det kommer man lida.
Så ja, jag tror att det omfördeskorna mest.
Men det är helt, nu är det killisar jag, men jag tror det.
Och vi ser ändå, vi har en liten ruta på våra egna e-handel.
Vi har ju 70 procent av omsättningen är ju återförsäljare, och så har vi 30 procent som går via e-handel.
På egna hemsidan så har vi en liten ruta som är så här, och den satte jag dit när jag själv packade orderna hemma med en fråga, är det någonting du vill lägga till i din beställning?
Nej, först har du BF Smart eller nyss ett barn eller nåt annat du vill lägga till i din beställning.
Och det är för att jag skulle veta, måste jag skicka det här idag eller kan du vänta till sin mån?
Och där har vi ju, alltså vad fjärde beställning har en kommentar i den rutan.
Och det kan vara alltifrån så här, åh jag har sett fram emot era produkter jättemycket, jag har hört jättegott.
Det kan vara, åh var med om ett akut tjejsasnitt igår, behöver du det här Issa?
Det kan vara, nej men det här är en present till mina, den är till min syster, men det kan också vara, det kommer ut en liten pojke, men på rutinen och tröjudet var det en flicka och jag kan inte knyta an till mitt barn.
Ja, och det här är liksom innan checken.
Och då märker jag ännu mer att vi är så himla ensamma i det här fast, vi är så himla många som föder barn.
Och var vill jag komma med det och varför svarade jag det?
Vad ställde du för fråga?
Jag tänkte säga att jag kan definitivt inte gå vidare i det spåret jag tänkte dra.
Min uppföljningsfråga på det, efter att du drar värsta emotionella svaret, så skulle min fråga vara, med all respekt för att ni är lite unga och sådär, men det är en väldigt logisk produkt som borde säljas kit till alla, så varför är den inte ännu större och ännu snabbare?
Det var min uppföljningsfråga.
Men vi kan fastna lite mot den här emotionella delen först.
För återigen, det är väldigt tydligt att du gör det här med en pensionsgrej.
Finns det en sån, inte baktanke, men finns det en sån tanke också att, vad ska man säga, samla mammor eller påverka sjukvården eller påverka efterläkvården?
Har du sådana tankar eller har du inte hunnit gå in i det än?
Nej, inte riktigt faktiskt.
Detta borde ju delas ut på sjukhusen.
Redan när du ska gå hem så borde det vara så här, det är klart du ska ha en liten flaska, det är klart du ska ha några binder och några trosor.
Det känns ju som ett ganska standardiserat kit på något sätt.
Ja, jag håller helt med.
Jag vet att jag försökte komma in på någon förlossning och jag mailar verksamhetschefen, jag får ingen respons.
Det här med att jag inte får någon respons, det är jag ganska van vid.
Men där förstår jag att det här är offentliga upphandlingar, det är statliga pengar.
Det är klart att det kan finnas i den här sponsade påsen som finns på de flesta förlossningarna.
Hur kostar det några kronor att vara med i en sån?
Om det är hundratusen färdslag, då använder sig bara en halv miljon att vara med.
Den ska jag lägga in i en produkt också.
Så det finns ju inte, där ryker alla mina, ja det går inte, tyvärr.
Men jag önskar ju i den bästa världen så ska det här vara ett kit som du självklart får eller finns på förlossningen.
Den finns också i inprinduschen, ja.
Men i spindan och de här trosorna, den här sickkudden, det finns ju liksom fler produkter och fler som jag kommer lansera i år.
Så alla de här är ju viktiga.
Och så hur ska man välja ut då?
Men inprinduschen är ju den som vi sålde 12 000 av förra året och det fälldes ju 100 000 barn.
Så det är bara åttonde gravid har ju köpt den.
Ja det är lite häftigt.
Det är superkort.
Okej, men då vill jag komma tillbaka till de hårdare frågorna.
Om man ändå har en så pass stor andel av marknaden som kund, och jag vet ju hur, som förälder så är det ju som man säger, man är ju ganska ensam hemma ofta.
Även om man har vänner liksom så är man ju lite ensam vid det man försöker hantera sin vardag.
Och då blir det ju mycket att man snackar antingen om man har sådana där mammagrupper, eller nu finns det ju olika mammaappar och chatar och sådana där grejer.
Men då pratar man ju om liksom vardagen och det är ju detta man pratar om.
Hur kommer det sig att inte alla har detta?
Eller varför har ni inte vuxit ännu fortare?
Vad finns flaskhalsarna i verksamheten?
Jag tror att det är tid.
Alltså min tid, jag har varit ensam och jag vet att så här, hade jag res kapital, hade jag res liksom två miljoner i början så hade det bolaget säkert varit mycket större.
Men det har ju varit familjepengar hela tiden som det rör sig om.
Jag har lånat pengar från min man eller i våra pengar, men förstår det står mellan, ska vi resa eller ska vi kasta in pengar i Katjans bolag?
Lite så och då har det ändå varit att han har varit en, han stöttar mig till 200% och jag säger hela tiden, älskling snakka för sur i oss.
Ja, ja.
20% fakes och sen bara 20-27% är det.
Så det har varit det, vi har inte vuxit snabbare för det har varit jag själv som kör på.
Det har varit svårt med alla besluten och allting själv, vilka produkter vi ska fokusera på, men göra allting själv.
Nu har det gått snabbare sen jag anställde Lisa.
Jag hade en tjej som hjälpte mig med marknadsföringen tidigare, men några timmar i lektorn, och också gjorde ett väldigt bra jobb.
Jag behöver någon som gör ännu mer.
Nu har jag en som jag ser som en partner, som är anställd.
Nu kör vi på och då går det lite snabbare och det är roligare.
Nu särskilt när Almas, vår praktikant som vi också kommer ha möjlighet att anställa på Timme snart, då har jag någon i Stockholm som jag träffar och då känns det lite mer som ett bolag.
Nu tar det fart och besluten går lite snabbare än att jag funderar utom själv och bollar med kompisar.
Då får vi ett annat hem på den lilla, när vi jobbar tillsammans alla tre.
Är det häftigt?
Är det att du aktivt vill vara?
Detta känns som ett bolag som hade kunnat, vad ska man säga, jag tycker inte alla bolag ska ta in pengar.
Jag tycker själv inte att jag ska göra det, jag har varit ganska avokal med det.
Men det här är ett bolag som jag faktiskt tycker hade kunnat må bra av det.
Har du valt att inte göra det eller har du bara, jag tar det någon annan gång, det är liksom inte prioriterat nu.
Nej, jag gick i de tankarna också.
Jag har varit på sån Almis pitch event, jag har försökt att rycka i några investerare och så vidare.
Men det har varit svårt med värdering, det är svårt att få andra att kämpa det här, bara för att jag passioneras för någonting som var i värdet och var, vilka möjligheter finns det.
Och det har varit svårt med så få produkter, det är sex egna produkter, det var ju några sju men så här, ja, jag hade nog kunnat göra det.
Men samtidigt så vet jag, inners inne så har jag inte känt för det.
Det har varit ganska skönt att vara ensam ägare där jag ska ta besluten själv.
Jag har hört att när man tar in kapital så ska man också rapportera till någon, du ska också kolla med någon.
Nu har det varit så här, jag vet så mycket pengar som finns på kontot, jag vet att jag har min mans stöd till 100 procent.
Så då kan jag sitta med en branschkollega eller någon som har en annan e-handel som bara kan jag, du jag ska beställa sådana här keftar, ska inte du ha en sån här keft som du står och är kul på?
Så säger han tjej, ja men typ lattemorsa.
Och jag bara, skit vad kul.
Såklart vi ska ha keftar som det står lattemorsa på, vi kör.
Och så bara tar jag det beslutet där och då, den dagen, och inte behöva kolla med någon partner eller man investerar.
Så nu tar jag 40 000 från kontot här för att bara köpa keftar som inte alls har någonting med min ålder att få göra.
Men bara för att jag tycker det är skitkul och bara, lä.
Det är klart att jag ska springa runt med keftar som inte har lappen hos jag på.
Så det är lite det som jag också känner när jag investerar.
Då blir det någon annan som ska säga lite vad jag borde göra och inte borde.
Och jag tror att andra sitter på så mycket kunskap.
Och lite som jag ryckte i dig för ett halvår sedan också att, du är så inspirerande och det finns fler inspirerande entreprenörer som jag känner, jag vill komma in i er hjärna, vad hade ni gjort i min sikt?
Så, absolut jag kunde ha res, men jag vet inte alltså.
Nej, nu är jag typ glad att jag inte har gjort.
Jag fattar, jag fattar precis.
Jag kände också med min tidigare partner, min kompis, att hon kom med en idé, men det här är mitt bolag att hon vill se vad min är och jag vill göra det här istället.
Nu känner jag nog att, nej, inte i dagsläget.
Och nu ser jag bara så här, det här kommer att ta fart.
Jag kommer att omsätta tre och en halv miljon i år.
Och då nästa år, jag har ändå dubblat varje år, och då känner jag så här, bara vi når ut till några fler länder.
Sverige har satt sig hundratusen barn, det är ju alldeles för lite.
Då når vi ut till andra länder så kommer det här fliga och då kommer jag att vara glad att jag kanske inte reser i kapital.
Men det är just kunskapen som jag hade velat gå in tidigare.
Någon annan som vet exakt hur jag ska gå tillväga.
För det är mycket tid som jag öslat på att jag inte vet, jag kan inte ha beslut, jag kan inte prioritera rätt.
Jag tänker att det borde finnas några episka mentorer därute som gärna feedbackar.
Det är ju, som du säger, detta är ju ett bolag som man antingen kan gå igång på siffrorna och möjligheterna eller så kan man gå igång på passionen också.
Det är ju när, nu är inte jag i den, jag brukar aldrig snacka om privata grejer så, men liksom när vi födde barn, då fick man ju en blick i sjukvården och hur den fungerar, och säg som kejsarsnitt och vanliga födslar och även hela problematiken där.
Det finns ju grejer som man blir väldigt engagerad i när man föder barn, när man inte föder barn, aldrig ens har reflekterat över om det finns eller inte.
Jag tänker att detta är ett sådant område som, ja, så om ni är duktiga på e-handel och expansion kan ni ju höra av er till mig Katja och ge lite tips liksom.
Ja, verkligen.
Jättegärna.
Jag vet att jag inte varit rädd att stå och låga om hjälp också när jag träffat någon på något investeringsevent eller något annat entreprenörsevent på nåt vis.
Men då har jag ändå fått väldigt mycket tips.
Det känns som att alla är väldigt hjälpsamma.
Men jag har ingen sån här advice.
Jag har ingen styrdelser eller någonting.
Så jag kör bara på med det jag känner för.
Man måste ju inte ha det.
Hur ser de andra länderna ut?
Har de samma behov om vi kollar direkt över till Norge eller till Finland eller Danmark?
Finns Apohem, Apotea och liknande företag i de länderna så man bara kan enkelt glida in den vägen?
Eller måste du gå in på en helt ny marknad då?
Ja det är lite att bli in på en helt ny marknad faktiskt.
I andra länder så har de, ja men det kanske är absolut att vissa kedjer kanske finns i andra länder men utomställda de andra.
Men det går, vi skulle i så fall gå lite för långsamt.
De största online apoteken där vi finns, finns inte i de andra länderna.
Så det är att reka en marknad på nytt och vilket vi gör nu också och kolla läget.
Och för mig är det ju fortfarande självklart att finnas socialtidförsäljare och då ska ju allting anpassas efter det lokala språket.
Och jag vet att många kanske tänker att man tar allt på engelska och alla kan engelska i Europa.
Och så kanske det är men för mig har det varit viktigt att på kartongen så är det, vi står liksom, vi ser dig, kom ihåg att ta hand om dig för det är du värd.
Om det står på engelska i ett språk där de fortfarande dubbar filmer, typ Spanien.
Så nej men den spanska gravida kvinnan kommer inte känna sig lika sedd när det står på engelska än om det hade stått på spanska.
Och då blir det liksom ett större arbete att ändra det här.
Jag vill ju att varenda beställning, och det är det här som är för-
och nattdelar med återförsäljare, absolut mycket högre volymer och förtroendegivande eftersom de får produkterna direkt och det kanske är fridslagt för att de beställer annat.
Men köper man via våra egna e-handel så får man ändå inpaketerat med silkespapper och det är liksom en fint listemärke, det är ett kort där ändå står ett så handskriv, ett kort med så hej Madeleine står det ju på det.
Och jag vet inte hur länge vi kommer att kunna göra så, men för mig är det viktigt för många skriver ju så här, åh vad fint och tack snälla och att de verkligen känner sig sedda.
Och jag vet själv när jag var gravida, när man hade beställt någonting till sig själv, då var det så här, det var så här mysigt att packa upp.
Det är inte bara någon albedon som man har köpt, som bara måste finnas hemma.
Du bär på ditt lilla barn där och du köper liksom allting.
Krämen är alltid lite så här mysigt till sin själv.
Ja, man blir extra glad.
Och det är det vi vill få ut fortfarande.
Jag vill att de ska bli sedda och att de ska känna att vi finns här och vi lyssnar.
Vi vet att det är skitstuppt och bara, ja, säg till, skriv.
Och det är därför vi har ett sådant här community.
När vi går ut på stories och pratar om aningar, så vi kan få liksom 80 svar utan problem.
Vi kan få 300 svar.
Det finns ett extremt stort engagemang och alla vill ju säga hur de mår.
Och det kräftar ju alla som mår dåligt också.
Det är inte en dans på ros är det här.
Och det är väl det andra tycker.
De är tacksamma över att vi ser dem under den här tuffa perioden.
Men på det temat då, har ni aktivt gått in i något annat land?
Och har ni i så fall skapat egna konton på det språket för att göra samma sak där?
Annars blir ju till exempel den kanalen på engelska rent konkret liksom.
Inte bara vad du önskar utan vad händer?
Ja men vi jobbar på det.
Och ja, vi håller på att gå över, jag säger inte vilka länder än, men vi ska smiga oss på och då är det det lokala språket som vi behöver skapa konton på, händsida, produkter, korten, beställningarna, förpackningarna och allt ska stå på det lokala språket.
Jag fattar.
Det är som du säger, det är ett jävla extrajobb för en känsla.
Men om det etableras, hur ser konkurrensen ut nu?
Nu finns det redan, när du tog in den här, vad kallar du den?
Peri-
Intin.
Intim dusch.
Men du sa något annat ord.
Peri-
Peri-bottle.
Peri-bottle, okej.
Det var det som var så svårt, vi kom på något fiffig dusch.
Vad ska vi kalla den för?
Intim flaska, det blev intim dusch.
Men har det börjat komma konkurrenter redan?
Ja, ja.
Vi lanserade i april 2021, inte i duschen helt nytt, och sen så i december då kom ju vår första konkurrent, eller konkurrent till Sverige.
Var det en annan, vad ska man säga, en individ som tog in det då och lanserade det?
Eller var det något apotek som lanserade?
Jag är bara intresserad av vilka som snappar upp det.
Ja, det var ett annat ganska stort företag som tog in mig faktiskt.
Så de var ganska stor.
Då hade jag lite svårt att konkurrera.
Då tänkte jag att vi får väl flyga på samma marknadsföringsvåg.
Men såklart det blev tufft för de var redan väl etablerade.
Så det var inga problem.
De kom in på apoteken långt före mig.
Med den här, som de kallar för intimdurs.
Kan ni inte kolla på ett eget namn?
Men ja, det är ju typ samma flaska.
Jag inspirerades av en flaska på USA.
Jag gjorde en större, en annan färg som mer anpassat efter skandinavisk design.
Men sen så kom de ännu en och nu är vi fem bolag i Sverige som har en intimdurs.
Och som vill samma sak.
Och handeln på hjärtat tycker jag att det är jättebra.
Vi behöver ha upp det här mer och visa för kvinnor att vi värdar det.
Så jag tycker bara att det är fint.
Men sen absolut så skapar en viss konkurrens.
Men jag har inte kämpat av den riktigt.
Jag har inte ställt någon minstnivårsförsäljning.
Det ökar ju för varje månad.
Men då känner jag också att okej, då kanske Sverige börjar bli lite lagom.
Inte riktigt mätta.
Det finns absolut mer det kan göra.
Men då kanske jag har mina chanser att expandera mer i de andra länderna.
För här föds vi som sagt bara 100 000 barn.
Och i Tyskland föds det 700 000.
Men i Frankrike, Italien, Spanien, det är helt andra siffror.
Och då om jag når ut till 12 procent här, så är det jättemycket.
Och så många fler kvinnor som ni kan hjälpa.
Det är det jag satsar på det här året.
Efter sommaren så kommer det att flyga, tror jag.
Du har ju egentligen engångsköpare.
Det är klart du inte har, folk kan ju få barn igen efter några år och sådär.
Men du har ju liksom ingen uppföljande försäljning, utan detta är ju till ett visst event, eller vad vi skall ha i en viss händelse då.
Hur hanterar man det och hur gör du för att de kunderna du ändå har ska bidra till att andra handlar?
Hur tänker man liksom kring marknadsföring och att synas?
Det är lite speciellt.
Det är det och det är väldigt svårt, måste jag säga, att vi har ett så kort fönster.
Vi vill ta fram fler, vi har en gravidolja som är bra att använda som sagt under graviditeten, så då hinner vi nå dem lite tidigare, men annars så är det ett väldigt kort period, några dygn eller bara några veckor.
Och sen så är den här efterår, sen så läker i kroppen.
Och sen så är det fokus på bebisen, det finns inte så mycket till mamman därefter, det är en vattenplaska kanske, jag vet inte.
Men det är svårt att behålla dem och det är därför vi lägger fruktansvärt mycket pengar på marknadsföring för att nå uttid.
Så det här behöver du den här första tiden.
Och sen så ja, några är kvar och hänger kvar i vårt nyhetsbrev, vilket vi är jätteglada för, men sen så är den tiden förbi.
Och då ger de det till en kompis eller till en syster eller tre år senare när de får sitt andra barn.
Men vi behöver ta in era kunder hela tiden.
Jobbar ni någonting med att utveckla, jag vet att vi följde sådana här olika appar där man, alltså allt från sådär flumiga skojappar där man kunde se att nu ser barnet ut som en valnö, nu är det en apelsin och så vidare.
Upp till liksom, det här hände den här veckan, det här sker den här veckan.
Är det något ni har, jag tror att de här var typ, inte alla men jag tror att någon till exempel var sponsrad av någon försäkring för det kom upp under typ tre veckor att nu är det bra att lägga in en försäkring.
Jag tänker att sånt hade varit ganska passande till er.
Nu är det tre veckor kvar, dags att köpa ett kit med det här, det är de vanligaste skadorna typ.
Men gör ni något sådant?
Ja men vi har haft samarbeten i de här apparna och det har också varit drivande så, men det har kostat väldigt mycket och då har vi känt att vi har testat, det har funkat jättebra men det går inte längre än.
Vi kan inte lägga så mycket pengar på den typen av marknadsföring.
Då lägger vi det hellre på meta och så ser vi hur pengarna kommer in via det istället.
Det här med andra försäkringsbolag har jag också kollat upp och vi pratar om flera miljoner i marknadsföring.
Så inte än tyvärr.
Men sen hoppas jag att det kommer vara självklart och vi har sett mer artiklar eller checklister av pack i BB-väskan.
Jag har varit jätteglad att vi har testat alla och vi har haft jättebra clickrate.
Men i längden så går det inte.
Vi behöver köra på Meta som är lite mer mätbart.
Nu när du kikar på de här ändra länderna, även om du inte vill berätta vilka länder, men ser behoven likadana ut?
För om vi snackar till exempel Sydeuropa, så är det ju BD'er till exempel, det är relativt etablerat eller uppskattat om man ska vara sån.
Så kan du sälja samma produktsortiment eller finns det redan där och du blir bara en Sydeu aktör som kommer in eller blir du ny?
Hur ser de här marknaderna ut?
Just nu efter, det har hänt så himla mycket i den senaste åren, så som det har hänt i Sverige att vi är fler aktörer.
Man pratar mer om kvinnorsvård på Spartum.
För tre år sen när jag kollade på de andra länderna så fanns det inte så mycket alls.
Nu finns det ju fler bolag och aktörer.
Och sen så finns det Amazon också, där det finns.
Där kommer de amerikanska jättarna också in på, som har redan 20 000 reviews på en produkt.
Då är det lite svårt att komma in i vår väldigt snarlik bild, vad designen som skiljer sig är eller storleken.
Och tillbaka till det här att jag vill att de ska känna sig sedda, och det får man inte riktigt när man köper det så.
Men vi finns ändå där och det är bara tiden som saknas att fokusera på till exempel Amazon.
Jag tror att vi behöver bli fler.
Så fast det finns andra aktörer, kanske just med den här produkten så kommer vi i en annan storlek.
Vi kommer med andra produkter, vi kommer med andra kit, som gör att vi, jag tror inte att vi kommer ha någon problem att sälja i andra länder.
Fast det finns andra aktörer.
Och jag tycker det är jätteviktigt att vi blir fler.
Jag tror också det.
Ibland kan ju försäljning drivas av att det blir mainstream på något sätt.
Jag tänkte bara, nu har vi fått höra dig och folk märker att jag tycker att det här är en bra produkt och sådär spännande.
Så du har ju fått lite halvkomplimanger här under tiden.
Då tänkte jag bara för att väga upp det lite, säga att du gör ju en av de mest horribla, jag vet inte om du ser så orolig ut, jag ska inte säga något hemskt.
Du gör ju en av de mest horribla sakerna jag vet, det är att du spelar in meddelanden istället för att skriva.
Jag har en partner i ett annat bolag som gör samma sak, och jag brukar bara skita i att lyssna på dem, men jag fattar inte folk som spelar in meddelanden och min kompis flickvän gör samma sak, det är fruktansvärt är det.
Har ni den kommunikationen på kontoret?
På kontoret och tänkte vi att jag och Lisa rast.
Nej men jag skickar sådana här hela tiden.
Varför kan du inte bara skicka ett vanligt meddelande så man kan läsa det snabbt?
Jag får inte ut så mycket, det tar mycket längre tid, och då får jag lägga in en massa emojis så att det inte blir någon sån här oklarhet i hur jag...
Nej, jag vill få ut det här så snabbt som möjligt på bästa sättet som det vore jag, som om vi skulle prata med varandra.
Då är det med en sån här voice.
Men jag förstår också, och jag har fler vänner som bara, jag läser det inte, tack och lov att iPhone transkriberar och skriver i text.
Då får man inte med punter och känslor ut ur uppstecken.
Jag är ju en väldigt känslosam person.
Jag skickar såna här voicen och jag förstår att vissa kanske inte läser dem.
Då behöver de inte, eller lyssnar på dem.
Och då, till och med Lisa har min anställd så ibland så glömmer jag att lyssna.
Och jag är såhär, okej det gör ingenting.
Det är inte så att jag säger någonting superviktigt.
Men ja, jag skickar den till dig, jag skickar till flera.
Men de flesta blir faktiskt så glada, det var kul.
Det blir lite mer intimt och personligt.
Och lite mer såhär, man kommer varandra lite närmare ändå.
Joer, jag erkänner att du kände såhär, nu fick du höra en fuk Katja.
Alla ni som lyssnar på detta, fan, skicka inga jävla voicemailgrejer.
Ja, värst jag vet.
Yes.
Stort tack för att du var med i podden Katja, och vilket spännande bolag.
Stort lycka till.
Tack snälla Joel, att jag fick vara med.
Superoligt verkligen.
Jag älskar hur du är ultrapassionerad kring detta, och bara, fan varför har vi inte detta?
Ta in det då.
Det är det mest typiska svaret.